You know,
there were elements in my
character that are optimistic.
You know,
I've,
I've looked,
for example,
I worked for a UN committee on the
relationship between economic development,
sustainability and I found out a variety
of things that were very optimistic.
Like the sock that,
you know,
the UN set out to have poverty between
2000 and 2015 worldwide and actually hit
that by about 2010 right?
So we're in that period of the fastest
transformation of the bottom strata of
the world's population into something
approximating middleclass that's ever
occurred.
And there's all these great technological
innovations on the horizon and it
looks to me like things could go
extraordinarily well if we were careful,
but I'm not optimistic
and maybe that's me.
I'm pessimistic because I also see that
there's five or six things happening,
all of which appear at the level of
catastrophe that are all happening at the
same time.
And so one of the things that I'd like
to ask you is like what do you see
happening in the next 10 years in,
in the universities are
in culture at large.
And I mean,
you just put forward a proposal for the
universities for the treatment of women,
which I think is very interesting.
One because women do have a
different timeframe than men,
but like what the hell is
the proper way forward?
I've been encouraging young men to tell
the truth and to take responsibility and
there's a huge market for that message.
But,
but I'm not convinced by any stretch
of the imagination that it's enough.
What like when you look forward
and you try to be optimistic,
what the hell do you see?
Well,
and in the largest scale,
um,
I'm concerned about the future of
Western culture because as a student of
history,
I,
it looks too much to me like ancient Rome.
Okay.
Would you became overexpanded,
uh,
which became an,
was at the mercy of,
of,
of bureaucratic,
um,
uh,
the creep.
Okay.
Yeah.
And I can imagine one of
this yesterday and it,
and,
um,
and Roman identity eventually,
got blur and okay.
In the,
in its incorporation of so
many different cultures,
which at first seemed like a
healthy kind of multiculturalism,
but eventually overexpand and
simply collapse of its own way.
I and I,
so I am concerned about the,
you know,
whether Western culture
is in a rapid decline.
I think it would be very easy because
we are so interconnected and so
overcomplex very easy,
you know,
to bring it to ruin it would only
take one major natural disaster.
We're going to do that.
But the University of themselves,
I mean,
I think people are,
are all of a sudden in the United States,
much more,
um,
attentive to issues of political
correctness because of the,
the riots at Berkeley,
which was the,
you know,
which was the capital of free speech.
I mean,
I don't mean the,
the free speech movement
happened in the spring,
uh,
before I entered college in 1964 to
one of the great principles and the,
in the inspirational
stories in my entire life.
Mario Savio was,
you know,
uh,
and uh,
assertion of,
of,
of the,
of the supremacy of,
you know,
free thought and free speech.
And I,
I though I think then perhaps,
you know,
we,
we might just have turned a corner,
but it's going to take a very,
very long time for the
university to be reformed.
I feel that the cafeteria menu,
okay.
Of,
of,
um,
the university curriculum
has to be abandoned.
We must return to historical,
uh,
courses that begin in the earliest
period in the Stone Age and antiquity in
order to give perspective,
you know,
to,
to our,
to our present doing analysis
of our president and culture.
I want,
um,
uh,
50,
50 to 75% of college administrators fired.
Okay.
And the money be transferred over okay.
To,
um,
to,
to faculty and to libraries
and two into two instruction.
Okay.
Um,
I think that,
um,
you know,
obviously the way things are being
people are being trained right now,
including at the public school level.
Okay.
Is I think that might think the
public school level has gone to hell.
And when my,
when,
when my mother came,
you know,
came to Dennis states at age of six,
they,
there were the old public school system
was so very strict and therefore she has
an excellent education,
you know,
and um,
did got all A's in,
in her,
even though she started
on not speaking English,
spoke without an accent,
etc.
Okay.
So,
so today this,
this kind of feel good public
school education at which is,
which is a form of ideology
in inductor nation right now.
So it's all about the no bullying.
Okay.
And it's not about,
yes.
Yeah.
So I mean,
I can tell them in my own students,
I mean,
I've been teaching for 46 years,
so I can tell this slow degradation
of public school education.
Okay.
Until they get to the point now that the,
that the students have absolutely no
sense of world geography of world history
and they know absolutely nothing.
They don't know anything
about wars and the reality,
the barbaric reality of
most of human history.
Okay.
And one of,
yeah,
what a fantastic culture we live in.
And so now it doesn't,
identity politics itself
has just got to stop.
I mean,
they was important once.
Okay.
I was a rebel against the wasp hegemony.
White Anglo Saxon Protestant of Germany.
In American culture it was,
it was suffocating.
I was raised in the 1950s or they went
when wasps controlled corporations and,
and,
and education and politics and so on.
And so identity politics
was necessary once.
Okay.
To do it.
We asserted gay rights.
Okay.
And he was,
it was stonewall rebellion
of 1969 we have sir,
we asserted,
okay.
The women's rights with the,
with the,
with the rebirth of second wave
feminism in the late 1960s okay.
But there's endless,
okay.
Preoccupation with,
with a fragmented identity,
we must return to the authentic,
that six,
his vision,
which is about identity coming from a
consciousness which transcends gender,
which transcends all
these divisions of race.
Okay.
Ethnicity.
Consciousness itself.
Okay.
All right.
Then there's no sense of that any longer.
That's what the 1960
sauce I see of that is
a complete abandonment of
personal responsibility.
Yes.
Because like that consciousness,
I think symbolically,
and I got a lot of this from
yoga and also for Merrick noise.
I mean that's the great logos of the West,
right?
That's the transcendent principle,
which is,
is respect for the primacy
of individual consciousness.
And what goes along with that
primarily isn't individual rights,
although that's built into it.
I mean that's the reason we have
individual rights is for respect for that.
But the responsibility that comes along
with being an individual instead of the
member of some group,
especially a victimized group,
which is like the usher.
I wrote an article with one of my students
who had toured the mass grave sites
and in the former Yugoslavia,
you know,
and have been explored,
exposed to that sort of thing.
And one of the things that our research
indicated was that the best predictor of
genocide is a victimization on the part
of the group that produces the genocide.
Right.
A sense of an accelerated
sense of victimization.
And then it's,
well we get them before they get us.
So when everyone's being taught now that
they're a victim and then no one seems
to have any sense that,
you know,
that's part of the essential tragedy of
being that life is suffering and that
and that and that and that,
and that the world rests on
a foundation of suffering.
It's nothing to take personally
and something to take
responsibility for instead
of blaming and,
and resentment and all of the things that
have polluted our universities and our
culture.